hi folks I'm Martha required I'm here to
tell you about a new business model for
open source software and I just yell
real loud we're closed tonight
monetizing application software is hard
enough right you could make a
software-as-a-service you could make
people pay for support you can make them
pay for a pro version with extra
features but if you're a library
developer like many people in this room
monetizing a C++ library is even harder
a lot of C++ libraries our header only
that means the source code has to be
available it's difficult to tell who's
downloading and using your code let
alone how to get money out of them so
you could put a big donate button on
your website but there's got to be a
better way I'm here to tell you about
that better wet and to boost blockchain
boost blockchain harnesses the power of
upcoming c++ 26 and 29 features such as
contacts for con steve al ranges
networking thanks to the pioneering
efforts of some of the people in this
very room we can use compile time
networking to get you paid in Bitcoin
when people compile your code it's
simple to use
here's your header we've got the header
guard of course have a header guard your
actual library functionality goes down
at the bottom above that we include
loose blockchain monetize on HPP which
is where all the magic happens we need
to provide it with two config options it
was blockchain fee is how much we'd like
to get paid on average when someone
compiles our header I pick the value
it's about half a cent right now notice
we're using boost units so it's all type
safe boost blockchain address is the
Bitcoin address where we want the fee to
be sent no that's actually a
user-defined literal how does that work
short version just a lot of macros you
don't want to know let's take a look at
how Blues blockchain works on the inside
inside monetize that HPP we spin up an
i/o service named iOS knows we're using
the i/o service from const a co not
regular SEO because we want it to be
happen at compile time now you might
expect const a CEO to be a keyword but
it's actually an identifier then we make
our static inline contacts were boom
monetized and we said it the result the
contacts per function that creates a
Bitcoin miner initialized with boost
blockchain address and we run it for a
length of compile time that's calculated
from our desired fee and then we return
true you might wonder why we use that
right shift instead of comma on that
line it's because right shift looks
cooler
blockchain minor overloads the right
shift operators so that we're able to do
this finally on the last line we static
assert that we've successfully monetized
our library let's look at this time to
function that computes how long to mine
for a time cue function right there it's
a constable phone
as you saw in the opening keynote it
takes in the desired fee again we're
using boost units so it's all typesafe
we make a couple of namespace aliases I
highly recommend you do this anytime
you're gonna be dealing with ranges I
actually recommend this by the way and
then we create a history object using
our i/o service and we fetch the
blockchain into a local variable some
compilers will run out of memory at this
point I think we're working on by the
way oh why didn't we say koa wait
context burg echo wait contacts for
being the same thing as regular KOA wait
it's like you know if Const expert work
on stuff you can put concepts for in
front of basically any keyword it'll do
something well if we used koa wait than
times who would have to be a co-routine
the point of co-routines is that when
you do a blocking operation such as
fetching the entire blockchain into
memory and the compiler the co-routine
can suspend and your thread can go do
something else such as compiled the
users actual code and we don't want that
so at least review on it's all
synchronous so this next fit this is all
bug stay under dangerous code we got the
last hundred transactions we extract the
fees associated with those transactions
that's a projection there with that
member we're extracting just the fee
member from each transaction gratuitous
use of ranges has the added benefit of
decreasing performance the point the
user may not even notice that we're
mining blocked fade in the background
now this next part uses range has action
accumulate that's not in C++ 20 but it
should be in C++ 29 if someone writes
the paper range is distance on the other
hand that is in C++ 20 that's a real
thing it computes the distance of the
range if you're familiar with some of
the other boost libraries such as file
system and a time you're gonna be
confused by that forward slash on the
last line the forward slash here
represents arithmetic division finally
we take that average transaction fee we
divide our desired fee by we multiply
the ratio by the time it took to create
those blocks
itter distance ed reduces kind of like
it or swap it or swap says I don't want
to swap these iterators I want to swap
but they point to so inter distance says
I don't want to subtract these iterators
I want to subtract what they point to so
we divide those two things we multiply
by the time and talk something like that
the important thing is this compiles all
right so let's talk about some concerns
you might have about using boost
blockchain in your own project could our
entire business model be defeated by
modules could someone make a module out
of your code and then used in all their
subsequent compiles without paying for
those compiles I'll believe it when I
say it you might also ask what if the
user just edits my header to remove the
monetization code well first of all if
that's happening you gotta get yourself
a better class of users the ones you
have can't be trusted but
our technical ways to mitigate that and
you could encrypt your code with the key
stored in the blockchain with a compiler
provides sufficient proof of work he
gets access to the key then it can use a
constant even to decrypt the source
coding the new compilation of reflection
and medical assets might also help also
if your users are doing something you
don't want them to do it might be a
problem that could be solved with
contracts future directions I've only
rarely thought of one running a Bitcoin
miner in the compiler is time-consuming
and wasteful especially with distributed
builds we might consider moving the
Bitcoin miner into the build system
however modules might make this a boot
point as modules effectively moves the
build system back and click compiler
boost blockchain thank you
[Applause]